-Today the President
melted down yet again
in a Q&A with reporters
after his White House
basically confessed to multiple
corrupt abuses of power.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
We say this a lot,
but it was true again today.
Donald Trump
talked to reporters,
and once again,
he lost his mind.
In fact, you should just assume
that's always the case.
His mind has always been lost.
At this point,
it would be more shocking
if CNN told us
his mind had been found.
"Breaking news --
Trump was normal today."
[ Laughter ]
The President has always,
always been unhinged,
and he's always hopped
from scandal to scandal.
But now, with the impeachment
inquiry intensifying,
it just feels like
more is happening faster.
The Trump administration
right now
feels like
the "SportsCenter" of scandals.
Instead of having to keep track
of a bunch of
different scandals,
like we did
for the first three years,
now we're just getting
all the highlights
crammed together at once.
"Trump just admitted
to a quid pro quo in D.C.
And now we take you to New York,
where Aaron Rodgers
just hit Rudy Giuliani
with a 38-yard touchdown pass
right in the [Bleep]."
So, as a result, there are
just more opportunities
for Trump to melt down
in public,
and that's what happened
again today.
For example, Trump said
this insane thing
about his abrupt and
widely criticized decision
to abandon our Kurdish allies
in Syria
who have been fighting ISIS.
-ISIS was all over the place.
I'm the one -- meaning it was
me, and this administration --
working with others,
including the Kurds,
that captured
all of these people
that you're talking about
right now.
Most of the ISIS fighters
that we captured --
we, we, not Obama, we --
We captured them, me.
So I'm the one
that did the capturing.
-No. No, you're not.
You're not the one
who did the capturing.
It makes it sound like he was
parachuting into Syria
on weekends like Tom Cruise
in "Mission: Impossible."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Trump also insisted once again
that his infamous phone call
with the president of Ukraine,
in which he dangled
hundreds of millions of dollars
in military aid
as part of a quid pro quo
to get Ukraine to manufacture
dirt on Joe Biden was perfect.
But today he seemed to forget
that it was a phone call
and kept calling it a letter.
-This thing is all about
a letter that was perfect.
You never hear the letter
anymore.
The whistleblower's account was
totally different
than the letter.
The whistleblower
gave a false account.
-The whistleblower
gave a false account?
You keep calling
a phone call a letter.
[ Laughter ]
Trump probably just changed it
in his mind
from a phone call to a letter
because he loves
getting letters.
He's always
carrying them around
and waving them in the air,
showing them off to reporters.
I mean, look at him.
He's like a high school senior
running into the house with
his college-acceptance letter.
"Mom, look, Kim Jong-Un
loved my essay!"
[ Laughter ]
Trump then had moved on...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump then moved on
to defending
his temporary decision
to hold next year's G7 summit
with world leaders
at his private golf course
in Florida,
which he rescinded on Saturday
after two days
of intense backlash.
Trump insisted
his golf course was
the perfect site
for an international summit.
-Everybody in the G7 would have
had their own building.
It was so good.
Florida loved it.
They love economic development.
It -- It's not because --
It's a beautiful place.
It's new.
It's been totally rebuilt.
Everything's good.
Got massive meeting rooms.
Unlimited security because it's
on, you know, hundreds of acres.
Best location.
Right next to the airport --
Miami International --
one of the biggest airports
in the world.
Some people say
it's the biggest,
but one of the biggest airports
in the world.
-What do you mean,
"Some say it's the biggest"?
It either is or --
It's not a mystery.
[ Laughter ]
We can measure it.
And as a reporter noted
on Twitter,
it's not even in the top 20.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Trump...
[ Applause continues ]
I mean, Trump talks about it
like scientists have been
working for years
to discover which airport
is the biggest airport,
like there are hieroglyphics
written on a cave somewhere
and archaeologists have been
trying to decipher them
in order to determine
whether Miami is one of
the biggest airports.
"The symbols are a plane,
a plus sign,
and a retiree
who lives in Palm Beach.
What could it mean?"
[ Laughter ]
Trump then defended himself
against accusations
that he was using the presidency
to rich himself
by lying about the fact
that he has no relationship with
his businesses,
and weirdly complaining
about a deal
President Obama made with
Netflix after he left office.
-I don't run my business.
I actually
put all the stuff in trusts.
They run --
And I didn't have to do that.
But under no obligation
to do it.
I don't know if you know it,
George Washington,
he ran his business
simultaneously
while he was President.
Many other Presidents --
there weren't too many
really rich Presidents,
but there were a few --
they ran their business.
Hey, Obama made a deal
for a book.
Is that running a business?
I'm sure
he didn't even discuss it
while he was President, yeah.
He has a deal with Netflix.
When did they start talking
about that?
-You think Obama was cutting
secret deals with Netflix
during his presidency,
and we just
never heard about it?
You're the one who's constantly
talking about your golf courses.
I never once heard Obama
end a press conference
by saying, [As Obama]
"And, uh, by the way,
if you, uh, like
what you heard today,
uh, check out
my new stand-up special
on Netflix.
It's called 'Barack Out.'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Then...
[ Applause continues ]
Then, Trump tried
a different argument.
He defended himself by claiming
previous Presidents
also ran their businesses
while they were in office.
-Other Presidents, if you look,
other Presidents were wealthy.
Not huge wealth.
George Washington was actually
considered a very, very rich man
at the time.
But they ran their businesses.
George Washington, they say,
had two desks.
He had a presidential desk
and a business desk.
-Oh, is that what they say?
Are these also the same people
who say Miami is
the biggest airport?
[ Laughter ]
What business
was Washington supposedly
running on the side anyway?
[ As Trump ] Many people
don't know this,
but George Washington
had a business
where he gave private boat tours
of the Delaware River.
[ Laughter ]
And on one phone, he'd be like,
"Uh, the British are coming."
And then he'd be like,
"We'd love to have your party
on our boat.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, bring chips and stuff.
[ Normal voice ] And
you might remember,
that this all started
on Thursday,
when Trump's acting chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney
announced, out of nowhere,
that Trump had awarded
no big contract
to host a major
international summit to himself.
-We're going to announce today
that we're going to do
the 46th G7 summit,
on June 10th through June 12th,
at the Trump National Doral
facility in Miami, Florida.
There's a long list of
the accommodations on site --
the ballrooms, bilateral rooms,
the number of rooms,
the photo ops,
the support hotels
that are there,
the proximity
to cities and airports,
helicopter landing zones,
medical facilities, et cetera.
-Not only did he
just brazenly announce
that the President
would enrich himself
by hosting an official event
at his own golf course
but then he did
an infomercial for it.
"There are ballrooms,
medical facilities,
helicopter landings.
And if you book
for Halloween weekend,
you'll even meet
our creepy siblings."
[ Laughter ]
Now Mulvaney...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mulvaney and Trump also insisted
the event wouldn't
actually benefit Trump,
because they would do it
at cost, or even for free.
But this claim that Trump
would do it at cost
was obviously a sham,
because as we know,
from previous events
at Trump resorts,
that's not how it works.
For example, at previous events
at Trump properties,
taxpayers have paid $546 a night
for hotel rooms at Mar-a-Lago
and $1,000 for liquor
that White House staffers drank
in one sitting.
The only way spending $1,000
for liquor in one sitting
makes sense is if you are
a White House staffer.
[ Laughter ]
"The other day he called the FBI
because he couldn't find
his remote control."
[ Laughter ]
We're all gonna die in jail."
I'm sorry, but if taxpayers
are gonna spend 1,000 bucks
on booze,
then they should get to drink
the booze themselves,
especially if we have to deal
with this President.
In fact, every Trump tweet
should come with an option
to retweet, like, or, "Send me
a bottle of whiskey."
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, after the outcry,
Trump rescinded the decision
on Twitter,
and then Mulvaney had to
go on the Sunday shows
to explain why Trump was
so wounded by all the backlash.
-He was honestly surprised
at the level of pushback.
At the end of the day, you know,
he still considers himself
to be in
the hospitality business.
-Okay, first of all, he's not
in the hospitality business.
He's the President.
Second, Trump was never
in the hospitality business.
Hospitality is when
you show warmth
and compassion
to guests and strangers.
Trump was in the "ruthless
real-estate ass[Bleep]
who stands like a baboon
on his hind legs" business.
[ Laughter ]
But this is such...
[ Applause ]
This is such a key confession
from Mulvaney
because it explains so much.
Trump still sees himself
as the corrupt real estate mogul
and reality star
who always got away with
whatever he wanted,
rather than
a government official
who's bound to the rule of law.
That's the Trump we saw
in that infamous phone call
with the president of Ukraine.
And during his press conference
on Thursday,
Mulvaney literally admitted
that they held up
the aid to Ukraine
as part of a quid pro quo
to investigate the Democrats.
-Did he also mention to me,
in past,
the corruption related
to the DNC server?
Absolutely,
no question about that.
But that's it, and that's
why we held up the money.
Now, there was a report -- -
-So, the demand
for an investigation
into the Democrats
was part of the reason
that he --
in order to withhold
funding to Ukraine?
-The look back
to what happened in 2016
certainly was part of the thing
that he was worried about
and corruption with that nation,
and that is
absolutely appropriate.
-Withholding the funding?
-Yeah.
-But, to be clear, what you
described is a quid pro quo.
It is, "Funding will not flow
unless the investigation
into the Democratic server
happened, as well."
-We do -- We do that
all the time
with foreign policy.
-You do?!
[ Laughter ]
So, not only did he admit it,
he said this isn't even
the only time they've done it.
In fact, many people
don't know this,
but, uh, Washington
had two desks --
one for business
and one for crime.
Mulvaney got even more brazen,
openly bragging about the scheme
and saying this.
-I have news for everybody.
Get over it.
There's going to be political
influence in foreign policy.
-"Get over it?"
I'm sorry,
but you don't get to talk
about an illegal quid pro quo
that's at the center
of an impeachment inquiry
like you're a cartoon mom
on a funny T-shirt.
"5:00 is wine o'clock,
and if you don't like it,
you can build a bridge
and get over it."
[ Laughter ]
Mulvaney continued to argue
that the President was allowed
to do whatever he wants
in foreign policy
and allowed to use
whoever he wants to do it,
like his personal lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani,
who is reportedly
under criminal investigation.
-Do you believe
that Rudy Giuliani's role
as an outside adviser
to the President
is problematic?
-That's the President's call.
The President
gets to set foreign policy,
and he gets to choose
who to do so,
as long as it doesn't
violate any law.
-Okay, but it probably did.
I mean, two of Rudy's associates
who helped him
dig up dirt in Ukraine
have already been arrested.
Remember these two
Halloween decorations?
[ Laughter ]
Lev and Igor, their real names?
I mean, the guys who look like
they just got arrested
for huffing
bowling-alley shoe spray?
The mobster versions
of Bill and Ted.
They've been in multiple photos
with Rudy, Trump,
and Mike Pence.
And you can't forget them
because they look like
they should be hanging out
with rocky and Mugsy.
[ Laughter ]
So, now Mulvaney's confession,
which comes after
Trump's own confession,
let's remember, has left
the rest of the administration
struggling with how to respond.
Yesterday, Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo,
who's also implicated
in this whole scheme,
was asked about
Mulvaney's comments on ABC.
And you can see his brain
short-circuit in real time.
-What I'm asking is,
would it be appropriate
to condition that aid?
-George, I'm not going to
get into hypotheticals and
secondary things
based on what
someone else has said.
George, you would have
never done it
when you were the spokesman.
I'm not going to do it here.
-Well, it's not a hypothetical.
We saw the chief of staff.
-It is, George.
You just said "if."
George, you just said
"if this happened."
That is, by definition,
a hypothetical.
-The chief of staff said it did.
[ Laughter ]
-George, you asked me
"if this happened."
It's a hypothetical.
-Wow.
Normally, when someone
takes that long
to answer a question on TV,
a red "X" pops up on-screen.
[ Laughter ]
Top five answers on the board.
Name a country
the President has colluded with.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
Sorry.
[ Applause ]
The answer we were looking for
was Ukraine.
[ Applause ]
Ukraine.
[ Laughter ]
Things are moving very fast
for Trump and his henchmen,
and that's because
the impeachment inquiry
has finally provided
a political process
to hold them accountable.
I don't know if any of these
guys will ever be arrested,
but if they are, I hope
the cops who do it say...
-I'm the one
that did the capturing.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]